If you are opposed to Muslims who have
read the Quran, which I've done, the
Muslim Brotherhood, the people, the
jihadis, right,
>> are not twisting the Quran. They are
being they are being consistent with it.
>> This is the new kharia in town. On the
day of judgment, the first thing we will
be asked about is our prayer. Now,
imagine being part of a project that
teaches thousands of people around the
world. For just £100, you can help teach
20 to 60 people like me learn how to
pray salah.
>> And when they teach their children
>> and their children's children,
>> the reward continues.
>> Do not miss the
>> donate today
>> and earn rewards that last beyond your
lifetime.
>> Go to the link and donate now.
>> Brothers and sisters and dear friends, I
hope you guys we are going to be
reacting to
Alhamdulillah. We're going to be
reacting to Sheh. I was going to say
we're going to react to react to. So, he
is here. I think he's in Israel if I'm
not mistaken. U the stolen lands which
is Palestine.
>> He's been to the Middle East. He he was
in Jordan. He went to Jerusalem.
>> Subhan Allah. Yeah. He might he might
they may end up uh killing him. But
here's a discussion he has with a
pastor.
>> Yeah. He not not just one. He had a
discussion with quite a few some Arab
ones like uh Yeah. I mean uh
>> he you see he he was an Islamophobe.
>> Yes.
>> But now he's
>> Yeah.
>> perception of Muslims has changed
America. Yes.
Let's see what he had to say. Let's
watch this video.
>> The Muslims who are threatening Israel
are Muslims who are threatening us.
Islam is a greater threat than the Jews.
>> Is the problem with the Muslims of
Europe that they're too Muslim or that
they're criminals?
>> Well, I mean I
>> that's the same thing.
>> It's not
>> that's the same thing. Can imagine can
imagine it's like it's like saying we
are by default criminals. And why are we
criminals? Why are we criminals my
friend? You are you are criminals. You
you were the biggest anti-semites. You
were killing the Jews and masculine them
and kicking out the whole lands. The
Muslims came and put them in there. If
anything, you guys are the criminals.
He's equating a synonym to Muslim and
being a criminal. Subhan Allah. Let's
carry on. What an absolute do bag. But
no one buys it anymore.
>> Not though.
>> Not though. Actually, the same people
who are like Islam is the problem are
the same people who brought us all these
Muslims here. The same people crying
anti-semitism constantly are the same
people telling us that we have to hate
Muslims because they're Muslim. How is
hating Muslims better than hating Jews?
>> Exactly. There you go.
>> You would have never heard Takson
speaking like that.
>> Exactly. Exactly. Exactly. Subhan Allah.
But let's let's kind this goes more into
the detail in let's see let's see what
happens now.
>> Israel apart from our defense guarantee
is meaningless.
>> Well
>> what what's its strategic importance
other than that are there trade routes
that go through it? Do we they have a
ton of oil we need? Like what is this?
You're like well we have to be most more
closed with Israel than any other
country. It's like well why and no one
can answer you because they're
threatened. Well so are a lot of
countries. They're not alone in having
neighbors that don't like them. But why
is that my problem? the people who don't
like them, the the Muslims uh
surrounding Muslim countries are also
people who don't like us and Muslims.
>> Who specifically? Which government are
you talking about?
>> Okay, this the government of Dearbornne,
Michigan.
>> You know, a lot of the Muslims in in
Dearbornne are Christian, but I mean a
lot of the Arabs in in Michigan are
Christian. So, just like in point of
fact, um and I'm okay with them uh
because they're fellow Christians, even
though
>> yeah,
>> you know, they look different. But I
rate that against the actual threats.
But think think of it this way. Um I've
I've seen the uh England and currently
every major city in England is governed
has a m Muslim mayor. The their
immigration policy has been disastrous
like like ours.
>> So I don't understand what's immigration
got to do with Islam. I'm so confused.
>> Meaning that the Muslims that the Muslim
are the the majority of migrants.
>> No, the majority of mig migrants in in
in in the UK are Indian. Indian and
Chinese. There's a lot of them coming
in. Yeah. Yes. And Nigerian all of them
Muslims.
>> And all of them are Muslims. I don't
understand what's he what's he talking
about? talking about like Islam as the
enemy or this that and what what's
he's an Islamophob
consumed with the hater and that
>> and he is a a a Zionist apologist
>> because
>> look at Taka Carlson is saying why is
this why is going no no no because they
don't like them and they don't like us
>> no but one okay one second you're saying
that the Muslim Muslims and and Islam or
whatever it is don't like you. Where is
your evidence? Where's your evidence
that we do not like the Christians or
the Jews? We disagree with your
theology. Let's get let's be be clear.
And you disagree with us.
>> In the Quran, in the Quran specifically,
it says
>> it says that you will find the closest
in
>> Yes.
>> in uh Yes.
>> Friendship.
>> Friendship to the believers are the
Christians.
>> Yeah. anything. It's the pagans and the
Jews that are distinct.
>> And not only that,
>> that the Muslims when the Persian
defeated the Romans, the Muslim No, the
Muslims were sad.
>> No, no, no. Yes. Yes. No, but but
because the the the Persian were fire
worshippers.
>> Exactly. And when they did one
>> when they did one, the Muslims
rejoicing. It was the same as the battle
of so they they
>> So he's making it seem as if Muslims
hate Christians or Israel or Jews
because they're Jews. That's nonsense.
If you one second, why do you like why
do you dislike Muslims? Okay. Is it
because they're Muslims? No. You believe
that we're barbarians and you invaded
our lands to liberate us? Okay, that's
the reason. Okay. So, meaning what? What
Israel is doing, the genocide that
they're committing, anyone would hate
someone committing a genocide. What's
that got to do with them being a Jew or
a Christian? It's absolute nonsense.
>> Someone could argue, as I I would, that
the Muslims who are threatening Israel
are Muslims who are threatening us.
Islam is a greater threat than the Jews.
>> Yeah. Is the problem with the Muslims of
Europe that they're too Muslim or that
they're criminals?
>> Well,
>> I mean I
>> that's the same thing.
>> It's the same basically meaning them
practicing their faith makes them a
criminal. Meaning for them to practice
their faith, you are a criminal. me
saying, "Is it is it the problem with
them that they're Christian or they're
criminal?" Ah, same thing. Them being
too Christian makes them a criminal.
>> Yeah, it it's not though, actually. And
it's not. And
>> no, the Muslim Muslim,
>> let me ask you this, and I'm totally not
for Islam. Okay. I'm a Christian.
>> Why are there twice as many Christians
living in Qar as there are in Israel? Do
you think
>> twice as many Christians in Qatar?
>> No, that that differently. He like his
face. Is that what is
>> yeah the Islamist slave state that we
heard so much about but there are twice
as many Christians living there as in
Israel and they can they can leave if
they want
>> they came freely but there twice as many
in Qatar. Why do you think that
>> build churches? Yeah, actually the state
gave them the land for their churches.
But um but why is that? If what you're
saying is that
>> sucker
>> I mean I mean even even if if they can't
can they build churches? Look, can they
build churches?
>> Yeah.
>> I mean I mean the thing is here even
Islamically we know that when Islam
takes over a land they we will not allow
you to build more churches but you can
keep your churches. So you have there
>> look
>> as far as I know
>> all the churches that are that that are
in the Middle East. Yeah,
>> they are from the the capilica church.
They are the nativity church. They are
from the time of of exactly
>> of Christianity. And not only that
Israel, one of the oldest man the the
the churches were bombed by Israel.
>> Yeah.
>> They spit at you, man. You absolute
They spit at you. They they
insult you. It's true because it's not
true. Actually, the reality that you
experience when you get outside the
American media biosphere is so
different. The reality from what you're
describing. Second question I want to
ask is how do we get all these Muslims
here after 911? They all came after 911.
>> Yeah.
>> Who encouraged that exactly? Who
encouraged that? And it's a lot of the
same people who are now encouraging us
to hate Muslims. ADL.
>> Oh,
>> Zidist. There you go. Zionist. The very
people who Subhan Allah. Look, they just
play you. Yes. If you look at Robert
Maxwell, his name Maxwell's father, he
wrote, he stole intelligence.
>> It's secret intelligence of the American
nuclear weapons program or something
like that and gave it to the Russians.
Okay. So, so there you go. They are your
enemies completely for that. They
encourage that. So, what is that? But I
know that the same people who are like
Islam is the problem are the same people
who brought us all these Muslims here,
>> right? Because I
>> feel like I'm being played a little bit.
That's all I'm saying.
>> Yeah, I I agree with that.
>> Oh, you agree with that? Oh,
interesting. Oh, okay. That was bold of
him saying it. Let's go carry on. The
same people crying anti-semitism
constantly telling me I can't have free
speech rights because there's
anti-semitism are the same people
telling us we have to hate Muslims
because they're Muslim.
>> How is hating Muslims better than hating
Jews?
>> Yeah, it's not. Exactly. If you hate
Muslims because they're Muslim, that's
>> the same as hating Jews because they're
Jewish.
>> Yeah, correct. I'm out.
>> But if you if you are opposed to Muslims
who have read the Quran, which I've done
a couple times. I read through the Quran
and and the the Muslim Brotherhood, the
people, the jihadis, right,
>> are not twisting the Quran.
>> I'm sure I would know.
>> They are being they are being consistent
with
>> Okay. Interesting. So, he's saying this
Muslim Brotherhood of Jihadis who he
deems it to be. My friend, you guys you
guys have committed the most massacre.
You know, I find it so rich. They have
committed the most massacres
>> from Iraq
throughout history.
>> History history
>> history. And he has the audacity to use.
So he's basically saying the ISIS and
these jihadis, whatever they are, they
are consistent with the Quran. Okay.
Where in the Quran does it tell us to
kill innocent men, women, and children?
Christian or Jew? Where? Where? Where?
Where does it tell us to carry out a
genocide that
>> ox camels and donkeys?
>> Donkeys kill men, women, and children.
They're quoting scripture, bro. The very
scripture that you carry in your hand,
they're quoting that. And you're telling
us if anybody is following scripture,
it's the Zionist and you guys. Because
Muslim scripture number one doesn't say
it. Number two, we don't we don't do
that. We don't go to
fight those who have fought Jew.
>> And in verse 16 verse 8, and Allah does
not forbid you from being just and kind
to those who did not your faith and
houses you out of your houses. But the
thing about it, the thing about it, you
look in in the whole they say in chapter
9 to Toba, the whole of Surah Toba.
Yeah.
>> Allah subhana wa ta'ala speaks about the
sanctuary in the in the haram.
>> Yeah. the sanctity of the haram that no
not to touch them that
>> you read the whole of the Quran chapter
8 speaking about the battle of B how the
Muslims they were they were tortured and
kicked out of their houses and and so so
every everything that you see in the
Quran when it comes to fighting it is
defend defend defend
>> that's true
>> and I see them as a far greater threat
threat to the West than the state of
Israel is. And so protecting Israel from
Muslims, you could argue, is a
roundabout way of protecting. It's a
process.
>> How's that work for us? We went to war
in Iraq in March of 2003 at the behest
of Israel. Flat out BB said it. Glad
you're doing it. And I don't there's no
debate about that. And then in the years
since, we've gotten millions of Muslims
in the United Millions since the Iraq
war.
>> Yeah.
>> So how's that how's that program worked
out for We didn't have any Muslims in
the United States when I was growing up.
And as our support for Israel has become
more and more fanatical, which it is,
it's fanatical. Can't even discuss it.
Anti-semite,
>> we've gotten more Muslims.
>> So, I don't think this works the way
that we think it does.
>> Right. I think that the whole system at
the top is demented.
>> Yeah. You think,
>> but that doesn't change the facts on the
ground. We We've got the problem that we
have in Dearbornne is a problem that
London has and a bunch of other UK
cities have. I would argue that because
we are involved militarily and on many
other levels in the Middle East at the
behest of Israel, we're there because of
Israel. We have a air base in Qar
because of Israel. We have all these
troops there because of Israel.
We have a lot of Muslims.
>> We have an air base in Idaho, Qatari.
If the deal,
>> but why is that? Because Israel bombed
Doha because they were doing a peace. We
were doing a peace negotiation with
Hamas. Why is that our job? Why is any
of this our job? We've invaded the world
and then we've imported the world. It's
the most happened to Britain that that's
why they got immigration in the 60s
because their empire was coming down and
they're like, "You're from Barbados.
You're from Nigeria. Those are British
colonies. You move here."
>> Right.
>> And we're doing the same thing. So, how
about we just we don't have actual
interests in the Middle East other than
oil. We Let's just pull back because
this is destroying our country.
>> Exactly. At least it's consistent that
it's it's a political it's political
reasons. Muslims
>> and resource and resources
>> and resource that you stole. Stop making
this about an Islam like we Muslims are
like so bothered of you worse than the
degeneracy that you have. We don't we're
not jealous of it at all with all your
respect. Okay. Okay. If anything they
come economically uh and it's got
nothing to do migrants.
>> And it's got nothing to do with we don't
like your way of life. Nonsense. No one
cares. With all your due respect okay in
our lands at least we might not be
financially that stable or whatever that
matter. At least there's dignity and
honor and there's respect for the elders
and so many other things.
>> Me and Sh went to the hospital today to
St. Thomases for
>> and guess what
>> his doctor was a Muslim girl. She she
was a Muslim girl in the place because
he goes to Haram fasting. So they all
started laughing cuz they said oh so are
we like a few of them were Muslims in
>> they'll corrupt you if the Muslims went
back. But anyways let's see what else
needs to be said.
>> Which is totally indefensible as far as
I'm concerned. How about let the kids
leave? No. How about let food in? No.
You have the most precise munitions in
the world, but you're blowing up
Christian churches and schools and
hospitals. Tell me why you're doing
that. What the Israeli government is
doing in Gaza is terrorism and
unconsionable. No one denies it. Tens of
thousands of children have been killed
in Gaza. It's just an absolute fact. I
visited some of their surviving siblings
last week and all of a sudden people are
like, it doesn't matter if the kids get
killed or they blow up two churches in
Gaza.
>> Were there tunnels underneath them?
>> They never claimed there were tunnels
underneath. No, I'm
>> Oh, what a nonsense. Could you get Was
there tunnels underneath them? What the
hell is this, man? You you can't you
can't blow them if there are stunners
underneath them.
>> You can't make this up. Just imagine a
Muslim nation doing what Israel has done
to Gaza. Oh my gosh. Imagine Epstein was
a Muslim. Who is behind all this
nonsense and fitna in the land?
Zionists. Come on, man. These audacity.
>> I'm just asking.
>> No, but it's like insane. And by the
way, if there were tunnels underneath,
sorry, you still can't blow up a
Christian church when all your money is
coming from a majority Christian
country. Sorry. There are limits on what
you can do. Okay,
>> tough luck. Anybody who's out there
trying to squatchch criticism of Israel,
ask,
>> "Is it like regrettable, sad, maybe even
immoral to kill someone, a child who did
nothing wrong?"
>> And if you can't say that, then we're
just operating from different worlds.
I'm sorry if you Why can't you say that?
Why is that so threatening to say
>> probably not a good idea to kill a
child? They will not say that. And they
much less apologize for it. Why bomb
churches in Gaza? Tell me. You've got
the capacity to set to put bombs in
people's pagers, but you accidentally
hit two churches. Not an accident. How
about you ask for our forgiveness,
Israel? That's I'm not going to lie.
This absolutely hilarious. Subh if you
think about it. Yeah, he's he's he's
right. Subhan Allah. He's he's right.
What excuses there to killing men and
children? Yes. Attacking churches. Why
are they attacking churches? Listen,
they despise you. She we as Muslims, we
love Jesus. We love his mother. The Jews
Zionist despise cooking. He's cooking in
feces in in the in the hellire in the
hellfire. this. You can't make this up.
How is it someone that despises you and
you fund him?
>> What did that uh what did that rabbi say
to Tommy Robinson?
>> Um is it which one? Which one?
>> The one that I was talking to him is say
to him, you were in the hellfire or
something like that or
>> to to
>> tommy Robinson when he was uh when he
had the talk with the rabbi.
>> I can't remember.
>> Yeah. They said to him something like,
"You are in hell or you you're British.
You got to go to hell."
>> Oh, yeah. Yeah. There's a special place
in hell for you.
>> For you. For the British.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> Okay. He was getting stuffed. He get
slapped around. He was getting slapped
around.
>> has has not allowed food aid in to 2
million people. There's no
infrastructure whatsoever. There's no
business. They flatten 70% of it. We
know that from satellite photos. And
like, so what is that? Their entire
country is dependent on US taxpayer
dollars. there would be no wars fought
by Israel alone because it's got 9
million people and no resources. They
have a reserve military. They don't have
enough people. A huge chunk of their
country doesn't work. But no one can
admit it. They all have to lie about
everything. If Israel does stuff that I
despise, my view is let's just I don't
want to pay for that. Okay, get out of
my country. Stop trying to censor me. Go
do your own thing in your own eastern
country, which is not Western. Sorry.
>> The West Bank, the conflict there is not
caused by Israel holding the West Bank.
Israel holds the West Bank because of
the conflict.
>> Is that is that is that stupid.
>> It's their fault. It's it's their fault.
>> Stupid idiot.
>> It's their fault. Can you imagine what's
happening in the West Bank
>> settlers and all of that,
>> you know? We know what is in a nutshell.
The reason why the Christians, Zionist
Christians, uh they support them is
because they just believe that uh when
Jesus comes,
>> he's going to convert them.
>> He's going to he's going to come and
massacre them. Yeah.
>> So, they're like, you know, they're
killing children by look how morally
bankrupt they are. They're so morally
bankrupt. They are saying at any cost we
as Muslims will never accept the
massacre of innocent women and children
because we have a esquetology that says
this or that strange.
>> So when Israel was formed the next day
or whatever it was they were invaded. So
a lot of what the the Israel has
>> the West Bank was taken by Israel in
1967 from Jordan.
>> Right.
>> Right. Right.
>> So Israel proper the West Bank is what
we call we used to call an occupied
territory. Now they have a new name for
it. A lot of Israelis used to say like
we've got Gaza, we have Golden Heights,
and we've got what we call the West Bank
and those are what we call the occupied
territories are majority Arab, majority
Muslim Arab, though tons of Christians,
fewer now. But yeah, what do you do with
that? You can't call yourself a
democracy if they don't have full
citizenship, but you can't give them
full citizenship because then they'll
vote you out. I mean, in a nutshell,
Subhan Allah, you can see very clearly
these people are the biggest
anti-semites. Christians are the ones
who've massacred Jews in history.
Muslims are the ones who've come to
their aid and help your ancestors.
>> Yes.
>> Immediat
Yeah. Throughout history. Look in
Morocco. Look in Tunisia and in Algeria.
Yeah.
>> All of them.
>> Yeah.
>> When the Spanish Inquisition was was
happening, who got them out of there?
>> World War II. Who they run to? France.
You give them identities. I went to the
masjid in France where the Muslims gave
identity to the Jews so they're not
massacred.
>> Get out of here. You are guys the
biggest anti-semites. Subhan Allah.
Alhamdulillah that Carson and many
people can ow real Christians are waking
up to this reality. Brother and sisters
and that's it. Nothing else to be said.
Today is Juma and we ask people to carry
on donating and supporting our cause and
sisters. Teaching people how to pray
salah in £100 can teach 20 to 60 people
to learn salah.
you get the reward of every action they
do. This year we pitted 70,000 mats in
Italian, German, French, Spanish,
English, and Japanese brothers and
sisters.
>> And and since you said it's the day of
jama, let's not forget to send our
praise and salutations and peace on the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam as as
many as we can.
This is the new in town on the day of
judgment. The first thing we will be
asked about is our prayer. Now, imagine
being part of a project that teaches
thousands of people around the world for
just £100.
>> You can help teach 20 to 60 people like
me learn how to pray salah.
>> And when they teach their children
>> and their children's children,
>> the reward continues. Do not miss the
kajaria.
>> Donate today
>> and earn rewards that last beyond your
lifetime.
>> Go to the link and donate now.